three-fourths of the people you will
ever meet are hungry and thirsty for
sympathy
give it to them
and they will love you
people are not interested in you
they are not interested in me
they are interested in themselves
Morning Noon
and after dinner
a person's name is to that person the
sweetest and most important sound in any
language
people are more likely to accept an
order if they had a part in the decision
that caused the order to be issued
you can make more friends in two months
by becoming interested in other people
than you can in two years by trying to
get other people interested in you
talk to someone about themselves and
they'll listen for hours
one reason why birds and horses are not
unhappy
because they are not trying to impress
other birds and or horses
[Music]
the only way to influence people is to
talk in terms of what the other person
wants
[Music]
every man is the damn fool for at least
five minutes every day
wisdom consists in not exceeding that
limit
ing carefully to a person is the
greatest compliment we can give him
expression one wears on one's face is
far more important than the clothes one
wears on one's back
[Music]
keep busy it's the cheapest kind of
medicine there is on this Earth
and one of the best
[Music]
a smile costs nothing but gives much
be more concerned with your character
ban with your reputation
for your character is what you are while
your reputation is merely what others
think of you
[Music]
develop success from failures
discouragement and failure are two of
the surest Stepping Stones to success
two men looked out from prison bars
one saw the mud the other saw Stars
our fatigue is often caused not by work
but by worry frustration and resentment
[Music]
ask yourself
what is the worst that can happen
then prepare to accept it
then proceed to improve on the worst
feeling sorry for yourself and your
present condition is not only a waste of
energy
but the worst habit you could possibly
have
if you can't sleep then get up and do
something instead of lying there and
worrying
it's the worry that gets you not the
loss of sleep
pay less attention to what men say
just watch what they do
[Music]
fear doesn't exist anywhere except in
the mind
if you want to change people why not
begin on yourself
that is a lot more profitable and a lot
less dangerous
knowledge is in power until it's applied
[Music]
fate hands you lemons make lemonade
criticisms are like homing pigeons
they always return home
most of the important things in the
world have been accomplished by people
who have kept on trying when there
seemed to be no hope at all
the person who seeks all their Applause
from outside has their happiness in
another's keeping
success is getting what you want
happiness is wanting what you get
the load of Tomorrow added to that of
yesterday
Carrie today
makes the strongest falter
the successful man will profit from his
mistakes and try again in a different
way
people sometimes became invalids in
order to win sympathy and attention
and get a feeling of importance
people rarely succeed unless they have
fun in what they are doing
happiness doesn't depend on any external
conditions it is governed by our mental
attitude
don't be afraid of enemies Who attack
you
be afraid of the friends who flatter you
by all means take thought for tomorrow
yes careful thought and planning and
preparation
but have no anxiety
[Music]
there is only one way to get the best of
an argument and that is to avoid it
if you want to keep happiness
you have to share it
flaming enthusiasm backed up by Horse
Sense and persistence
is the quality that most frequently
makes for success
[Music]
every successful person loves the game
the chance to prove his Worth to excel
to win
inaction breeds doubt and fear
action breeds confidence and courage
if you want to conquer fear Do not sit
home and think about it
go out and get busy
[Music]
arouse the other person an eager want
he who can do this has the whole world
with him
act as if you were already happy and
that will tend to make you happy
people become lonely in old age because
in their youth they didn't cultivate
relationships and connections that could
have sustained them through the ups and
downs of life people don't have many
friends because as kids they didn't
learn to trust people
it's never too late to start building
meaningful relationships and investing
in the people around you
an individual who unselfishly tries to
serve others has an enormous advantage
man is not made to understand life
but to live it
[Music]
smile
today is The Tomorrow you worried about
yesterday
the desire for a feeling of importance
is one of the chief distinguishing
differences between Mankind and the
animals
personally I'm very fond of strawberries
and cream
but I have found that for some strange
reason fish prefer worms
so when I went fishing I didn't think
about what I wanted
I thought about what the fish wanted
are you bored with life
then throw yourself into some work you
believe in with all your heart
live for it die for it and you will find
happiness that you had thought could
never be yours
let's not allow ourselves to be upset by
Small Things We Should despise and
forget
remember
life is too short to be little
[Music]
one of the most tragic things I know
about human nature is that all of us
tend to put off living
we are all dreaming of some magical Rose
Garden Over the Horizon
instead of enjoying the roses that are
blooming outside our Windows today